hey this is presh talwalker a conical
vessel with vertex downward contains
water to a depth of five centimeters on
adding 720 cubic centimeters of water
the level rises to 10 centimeters find
the quantity of water which must be
added in order that the level may rise
to 15 centimeters
I think arth for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
let's first sketch a diagram we have a
conical vessel with its vertex pointing
downward
it contains water to a depth of five
centimeters
now
720 cubic centimeters of water are added
and the level rises to 10 centimeters so
we're adding a height of 5 centimeters
we now want to know the quantity of
water which will get the water to rise
to 15 centimeters which will be another
five centimeters so we need to calculate
this volume of water
so how can we do that
let's first draw radii of each of these
three cones let them be a b c in
increasing order
now we have three similar right
triangles here so we have C divided by
15 is equal to B divided by 10 is equal
to a divided by 5.
we'll solve these equations so that we
get expressions in terms of B
so we have a is equal to B over 2 and C
is equal to 3B over 2.
now the volume of this truncated cone
will be equal to the volume of the
larger cone minus the volume of the
smaller cone
the volume of a cone is pi r squared
times H all over three so we can
calculate the volume of each of these
cones so we have 720 which is the volume
of the truncated cone that's equal to pi
b squared times 10 all over 3 minus Pi a
squared times 5 all over 3.
so let's simplify this equation
we'll multiply both sides by 3 over pi
then we know that a is equal to B over 2
so we'll substitute in
we'll simplify this equation
and then we'll solve for b squared
so we get that b squared is equal to
1728 divided by 7 pi
now we'll put this to the side
now we want to calculate for V so again
we need the volume of this truncated
cone which will be the difference in
volumes of the larger cone and the
smaller cone we can use the formula for
the volume of each of these cones to
calculate V is equal to Pi c squared
times 15 over 3 minus pi b squared times
10 over 3.
so let's work on this equation
we'll multiply both sides by 3 over pi
then we substitute in that c is equal to
3B over 2.
we will then simplify this equation
and we will solve V is equal to 95 pi b
squared over 12 but we've solved that b
squared is equal to 1728 divided by 7 Pi
so we substitute in and we get that V is
equal to 13680 divided by 7 which is
approximately equal to
1954.29 cubic centimeters and that's the
answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world problems one video at a
time